finished off the date in your chuev saloon buchanan
bar
winding stop a chance with a rut himself one
screw without rest jay garrick the waves beat
has become a team pro send his fairy
sofa cover and one of them she
throws her yes and you conservancy
favorite wings mrs becoming half a gour
pineapple  PTO engineer and styles like fms and
the basis of jam real haen kendo 17
[music]
jean
de way
alice now papa paul to the end fine
pause and nevis many of my Melitopol
friends today have
become more active and
are interested in writing and asking me what
to buy during  lviv now for 20,000
dollars, for example, what kind of real estate
for many of them is still a little
terribly incomprehensible unknown,
but they understand that here they could
hide from possible aggression
.  the creatures
miles of cola spur about this dialogue
and elsa the assassin seemed to like it because the
camp has its own ways of tires and for single
out about  a phenomenon of ours
turned to me with a request to help
them rent apartments at home and one
company even asked me to
help rent hotel rooms
for a large company from Kharkov and
on the 1000 diplomat website of the company for a mustache
preservative big business konkin family and
flora pxl before the
merchant to be replaced by that  when it’s important
that you keep shopping, it was and people are
dashing cube and shafts an apartment law bayonets their
relatives for rejected from to what so beyond the
cordon, today it’s more fright to go
to that and people from the code with central
feelings to ukraine to here on mothra is small
and west  the company arrived 100 nasty
and 2
mice of varying degrees with repeat gai muscles of the test
come and go to the company the courts were even
before the cordon let's say u like it so much
zaka fly the price of the cake is too rich IT people
well and today wise to my west the
shark component of paris it is in the mail for me
I’ll be in and you’re here the carcass itself in the light of the center and
for our unbearable cabin a dwelling for evil
opponents,
she brought the James style to that fab  rick now tell the old body from the arrest least gibberish and in the quest and apartments at stone fom people looking for safe even in liv i don't feel panic i don't feel alarm possible because i'm already here of course maybe because i have the opportunity to take all my loved ones if something happens here, I continue to send offers to my friend from Melitopol who here wants to buy something, at least a small smart some kind of housing and everyone understands that if something happens they have somewhere to run, but they don’t understand how they will run, as one of mine said a friend who has already rented an apartment here for her parent, that you understand that there will be a line of cars from Pobedy Avenue in Kyiv to Freedom Avenue in Lviv, so everyone died, they are also aware that it will not be easy to move here either [music]